you said when you were growing up your
mom was very open about discussing
sexual matters sex yes
yes I like to say sexual Maddox who will
matter yeah okay uh I'll just cut to the
chase
yeah my mother taught me how to go
downtown taught me how to knock the man
off the boat taught me how to using i'm
just still assuming this is she taught
you on public transportation had a girl
my mama taught me how to eat the cookie
or oral sex Conan I think you should go
yes back it up okay explain this okay
yeah there's a lot of questions yeah III
was I was in my early 20s I just come
home from college and we happen to be
sitting around in the family room not
only me but my buddies and their
girlfriends and she not only talked me
and my brothers and my boys but also the
women how to do what they needed to okay
to hold on when you said he taught them
if she you know said us using charts as
she used dry erase board yeah what is
she doing my mother has a very extensive
video collection and she would put she
would put the videos on uh-huh and go
into graphic detail as to what was
happening on the video and what and what
either me and my brothers or the young
ladies should be doing okay well okay
okay here we go we got yeah let's let's
go let's go come on
okay what was her motivation for
teaching you guys how to make a woman
feel good in that way okay all right
her motivation was my father didn't know
how to eat
so she said I will be damned if I send
my three boys out in the world not
knowing how to do that so it is my duty
to teach you to do this properly because
your daddy didn't know what the hell he
was doing see the short the short
version would have just been good
citizenship that's the reason behind it
okay so she wanted you to okay good so
it was yeah moving forward
got this up not me what about the win
what was she telling the women how
graphic can we get on your show come on
it depends if it gets really crazy okay
we might have you arrested okay wouldn't
be the first time well with the women
there was a vein involved okay we don't
know I need to know about that how did
everyone react to this I mean what
sounds like it was just people just got
out there yeah it was it was it was a
great time it was a great time yes I
mean it was fine I mean we laughed at my
mother sitting up there teaching is up
you know what we thought we knew yeah
okay yeah all right and it turned out to
be good knowledge it turned out to be
great knowledge okay yes okay did she go
give class
[Applause]
mom I think Conan what's the one-on-one
[Applause]
what I want to know as if you ever ever
told anyone afterwards like my mom
taught me back and I would actually call
my mother on the phone and say mama
they don't believe you taught me this
yeah and every girl did we do it right
Wow
all right none of this there's none of
this hair is on television and all if
you keep your mouth shut this didn't
happen this is like area 51 none
you